what access did you have and earlier on
in the messaging you said
the general key was photo memes
text messages instant messenger
so you guys were able to see what's
being said in the instant messenger and
text messages or no
yes also whatever we post there and
we're communicating you see all of it
yes absolutely
[Laughter]
everything that's communicated here if
you wanted to see all of it you can
easily see it yes and
you have access to who like
do is there levels of clearance on who
you have access to want to be able to go
see let me see if this one guy i don't
like let me see what he stands for i'm
gonna go see what this guy's saying to
this person here could you do that or
was there limitations to what they sent
to you
no
uh in the general queue there were
limitations where i was there were not
were you ever tempted to see some
conversations of people that were higher
ups or no
i was tempted yes but not specifically
higher ups i have to be honest politics
isn't my thing i was more curious about
seeing what my cousin was saying up in
georgia
if i have to be honest imagine like my
cousin doesn't like me
i i'm not a political person even though
when i was in cognizant it was very
political in there
but i'm just not much of a politics
person to begin with
and and you know what's the uh unique
thing about talking to you you're very
sincere you're just like this is this is
who i am this is what i'm doing
were you again i don't even know like
what what do you know about shadow
banning that we don't know about you
know like you know when you
see sometimes you create content and all
of a sudden you're like wait a minute
like you'll see videos that are momentum
momentum momentum
and typically when a video's momentum
goes away it's typically a drop off like
this
right and it goes away it's just kind of
how it works i mean i've been doing this
for a long time we got a few billion
views total online
but sometimes you would see video goes
like this like this like this and then
sometimes it just goes boom
that's not possible for
a video to do that there's got to be
something that automatically brings it
down 90 within a second
what is shadow banning something that's
a real thing that's taking place and
who behind closed doors is moderating
who they don't want to get exposure and
who they want to get exposure
so the whole process about shadow
banning is what they're trying to do is
content that they feel is either
offensive controversial or any sort of
content that is just um they feel like
will cause real world harm
they will tend to try to stop it before
it becomes too viral so they don't want
it to become a viral message they don't
want it to go mainstream so they usually
just try to cut it off right at that
tipping point right before it would
become viral or mainstream
uh the people that
focus on that type of content were not
in cognizant they were with the facebook
queue in general they were the ones that
actually worked with facebook itself
um but for shadow banning as i said
before it was very much that they were
just trying to cut off things that were
trying to almost on the verge of being
viral
there were things that could have that
could range from hate speech
there were things that could range from
political
ideology they could range from things
that could be misinformation about uh
medical uses medical diagnostics
i mean i'm sure a lot of people have
seen everything go along with the kova
19 response and how facebook has been
working with that
um so it's just things that
are going and they're on the verge of
being viral but they have not quite made
it yet they just kind of cut it off
right then and there before it gets to
that point so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]